[Music]
up next an interview with m.a farber
investigative reporter for the new york
times and co-author of outrage the story
behind the tawanna brawley hoax
mr farber joins us to discuss the events
surrounding the new york case as well as
the investigative findings of police and
reporters in later months
he draws upon his own experiences having
worked with the new york times team
covering the case in 1987.
[Music]
m.a farber co-author of the book outrage
the story behind the tawanna brawley
hoax
why a book
why the truth
the book is grows out of the new york
times coverage
of the case but
unless you've saved all those articles
and you want to and you don't want to
know anymore
this is the place to find out the truth
of the matter
who is tawanna brawley
dwana brawley it was a 1987 a 15 year
old girl who
was found
with in a garbage bag in a rural
community north of new york
with excrement smeared on her body and
racial slurs on her clothing in her body
whose family and family advisers later
claimed had been
subject to four days of rape and
sodomization and
other brutalities
what happened to her was she ever
indicted or convicted
well she was the subject of the attack
as as
the family portrayed the incident
um as the book points out we believe it
to be a hoax
there was no racial attack there was no
attack
of that nature on tawana brawley at all
um
toronto brawley
has never i think except
in the place where we included in the
book uh told
the truth of the matter
and
she is uh
today like us all a few years older a
student
um college student now
and
the
turmoil that ensued as a result of what
was
a false allegation
is beginning to be tempered i think
talk about the the legalisms of what
happened around this incident who
charged
whom with what well she her story
as filtered through the family advisors
and the family
was that she had uh
gone to see a
a boyfriend
um
who was in jail at the time in another
community she came home in the evening
tour into her own community of wappinger
falls new york i got off a bus was
seized by a group of men
one of whom was wearing a badge and
indicated he was the police
was taken to a wooded area
was raped and otherwise brutalized over
a four-day period and left for dead
in this garbage bag
that essentially was the story but what
i meant by that was what happened after
that in in in the legal world in the
legal world what happened after that is
uh the family
put forth this story through
their advisors and
the state of new york embarked upon
an exhaustive investigation the estate
of new york and the fbi and others
exhaustive investigation there was a
grand jury that
was convened and that reviewed all the
evidence
and
and some six months later
in june of 88 concluded that
[Music]
that
generating 1899 was concluded that uh
that there was nothing inconsistent
uh in the evidence with having been
self-inflicted so it was dead then
legally after the grand jury reached
those conclusions
well um one of her lawyers has been
barred from practicing in new york until
he cooperates with a
um an official um inquiry into
his his
um
handling of this case
another of the lawyers faces the same
possibility which lawyer has been barred
alton maddox
um
there is a civil suit
brought by
an assistant district attorney
in this county north of new york
dutchess county
um against the family advisors and
members of the family as well i believe
because at one point during this case
they
accused him of being one of the rapists
let me uh i've got here a
washington post
newspaper clipping
from a couple weeks ago
actually september 5th wednesday front
page of the style section
and because it
it has something to do with all this i
thought it might be interesting to get
your opinion of it
al sharpton in his own image and here is
al sharpton
this is all about al sharpton and how he
does this kind of thing
why do we care who al sharpton is
who is he
well
al sharpton can be found
moving around most
matters that
most public matters are controversial
public matters that involve race in new
york
uh and elsewhere indeed today uh he is
in atlantic city
uh wants to do something about what he
believes is racism down there and
tomorrow uh the other day
i say the other day in that year of
tawana brawley he was north of new york
he's a movable feast and
if you want to believe al sharpton he is
um
he is on a uh
crusade
to
rid the united states
of what he sees as uh 400 years of
racism
you want to believe some others he's a
charlatan pure and simple
for myself i think he's more complicated
than
than he's generally portrayed
the
i know this that
that while the polls show that he has
little following
that you can't go out on the street with
him
and i'm not speaking now of protests
that are organizing anything without um
blacks lifting up their hands and you
know go owl go go rev you know go get
them that sort of thing
there's unquestionably you know some
sort of
of
of
grassroots
sentiment
among poor blacks
that he draws upon and reflects
and
and
that's a support that he can count on
and politicians in new york um
have to reckon with that to some degree
where's tawanna brawley today
today tawana is a
sophomore i believe at howard university
here in washington has she ever talked
to anyone about
her situation
she made some statements initially
that
again were filtered through other people
and that are
it's hard to
um
to to draw a coherent account from
but later on she spoke to a boyfriend
daryl rodriguez
and this is to be found in the book
um
and there according to rodriguez she
relates uh that uh
that this was not the truth that she was
not attacked and indeed it was uh a
hoax
that's that's where you'll find that
account okay by the way the picture we
just showed was from the washington post
article because there are no pictures in
your book uh before we go any farther i
want to hold this up and and see
jane if we can get a close-up of these
co-authors of yours first of all who are
they
a robert d mcfadden
ralph blumenthal m.a farber e.r ship
charles strum and craig wolf all of the
new york times all work for the new york
times
just as a
question i'd like to ask you about their
background any of these men black
er ship is a woman and she is black
and because the reason i ask that is
that
this book
is full of uh a lot of
discussions about the race issue and did
that worry you at any time when you
wrote this piece that most of the people
involved in this are white
well
no i wouldn't say it worried me at all
the
but
i'll say too that e.r ship is
a tough lady
um
proud of her of
blackness and
she
read and re-read every word in that book
i think from her
particular perspective
not only as a reporter but as a
young black woman
and
she signed off on it as well okay one of
the other things i want to ask you about
is one of the early chapters you talk
about the diner
the smith diner i believe
uh who did the work on largely shipped
she did the work would you explain what
that's all about and how that fits in
this book well
there's a
running through the book is a chorus of
voices so to speak
of people who
happened to frequent a diner in brooklyn
uh and who also some of them had some
association with the case
and um we used this diner as a sort of
greek chorus if you will
of
of local
black people reflecting upon the events
as they're developing and we intersperse
that through the chapters to give the
reader some sense of how what is
happening at any given time
is being seen by
at least some element of the black
population
how did miss ship do it
well she
she is
she knows those people
and
and i think she has their confidence and
she has their confidence perhaps more
if i may be frank about it probably then
i would be able to gain it did she just
go into the diner time yes
talk to the people there
at the end of the
book the squire
by remembering the right name
the squire uh one of the men that sat
around the table and talked about this
well by the way everything they talked
about was was black everything all their
discussions revolved around things black
did why well because i think we say in
the beginning that this is the kind of
place in brooklyn where
where um
where what counts is what um
has an impact upon black people
that you know it's a um
[Music]
the discussion is is more apt to focus
uh
upon a situation like tawana brawley
than it is upon
the passage of uh
of some farm bill on the hill
yep go back to the the final uh the
epilogue here and the squire walks out
um
what's this about
i think it's about conscience and about
the question that
the book is all about in a way and that
is um facing the truth
and the squire having reservations now
you see about whether
tawana brawley
you know was indeed raped
and
[Music]
and that's what that's what we're
getting at here that i mean i i think
that if there is
i think it's principle to this whole
story to say that that
if you're going to
serve the cause of promoting racial
harmony
you can't
take something that isn't so
something that is essentially not true
and hold it out as the truth simply
because
it serves an immediate end
the immediate end of tawana brawley's
advisors though not of tawana brawley
and her family initially
it was to
put this in the stream of anti-black
incidents
uh that um that
you know that or pock marks in american
history i mean that are worse than that
and um
and um they shouldn't have done it and
um they should have my opinion no one to
get out and
when to say this isn't so
one has to remember that
that when this case came along when this
hoax was developed
[Music]
um it was in the aftermath of a terrible
incident in new york where
a young black man named michael
griffiths
was uh driven onto what was was chased
onto a highway in the howard beach
section of queens in new york
uh where a car struck him and killed him
by a group of white youths
in what was clearly a racial incident
um and
you know
al sharpton and and one of brawley's
lawyers automatics and vernon mason were
uh certainly maddox and sharpton were
involved in that case as well
and um
there it was the real thing
and they came away from that case with
with enhanced credibility for having you
know argued that that case had to be
seriously uh and uh and
thoroughly prosecuted
they soon found themselves
admired in this
and while they would argue today they
were here
that
um this girl was indeed a victim of rape
and that it's all
true um i think that uh they made a
serious uh mistake and that uh
it's long past time they would
acknowledge that
back to the diner um and the squire and
the group sitting around the table
every day drinking coffee talking about
things black
at the epilogue when you talk about the
square walking out and having doubts the
suggestion is made that he better not
say that publicly
or someone might kill it a lot of people
today that that's right
i'm going to kill him but but spurn him
i think there are
a lot of people today
black or white perhaps some
who
who still believe
that
a 15 year old girl would not have
put
excrement on herself written racial
slurs on herself done these things that
there must be some truth to it and there
are some other people who feel that it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter whether
it really happened because because these
kinds of things happen
because black women have been raped very
often because because a black man was
chased onto a highway and and in the
bensonhurst case in new york uh last
summer
in the summer of 89
a young black man who ventured into a
white area of brooklyn was shot to death
by a group of whites well he wasn't shot
by a group of whites but he was shot to
death
by one white in a group of whites who
were
uh who were uh
questioning them about their presence in
that neighborhood
um
so so it's easy you know blacks
rightfully see that these kinds of
things happen
and to some of them i dare say it no
longer matters whether it's true or not
but it matters to me
and it matters to the others with whom i
worked and who wanted to
put in one place
what we believe to be the best single
record of this whole episode it matters
to us because what we essentially do
and is
is
trying to to tell the reader in the
newspaper and try to tell the reader
much
fuller version here what is so
and we it counts what is so
it not only counts historically
but it helps to uh keep things on an
even heel
and and i think that
um that
that you know what began as a case of a
situation
where a young girl
and her mother wanted to um avoid the
wrath of her stepfather
uh who was uh angry at her staying out
late by possibly punish her
perpetuated something like this
that it would have been far better and
never meant to go anywhere beyond the
family you see
but far better once it hit the ball had
started rolling to stop the ball
you know the interest of of of racial
harmony but the interest of of whites
and blacks alike would have been served
better
how long you been with the new york
times
24 years what does ma stand for
m a stands for myron abba
where were you born i was born in
baltimore
where did you go to school
i went to school with baltimore city
college university of maryland
northwestern university what was your
first job
i was getting a phd in history at
northwestern
which i abandoned and um
and uh i wanted
i wanted uh
to mix up the real world with academe
the scholarship and
and um i had gone to high school with
the sons of the editor-in-chief of the
baltimore sun and
and i went to see him and
told him i didn't know how to type and
probably didn't know how to think
well we're in an organized fashion
but like trying my hand in journalism
and he directed me
[Music]
north
and
i had my first job at the hartford
current and i was there for about
two years when i was hired by the times
and i've been there since
how do you describe your
responsibilities as a new york times
reporter what area are you concerned
with
[Music]
i move from
generally one sensitive
subject to another
um
unlike many reporters
far and away
most of what i do
involves situations or cases where
people
don't want to talk to me
and
much of my effort is spent persuading
people to talk about things that they
may not see in their own self-interest
do so it's a it's
that kind of work
i was recently involved
with my colleague ralph blumenthal in
stories involving a
priest a roman catholic priest in new
york father bruce ritter who run ran
covenant house until recently
and
there was another investigation that
took some months
and i was involved recently in donald
trump's affairs
not financial affairs and
[Laughter]
it
goes on things like that
over the 23 years you've been in the new
york times which are what are some of
the bigger stories besides the one you
mentioned you know maybe going back a
few years that you worked on
well
i suppose the
the
i mean i've done all sorts of things uh
you know the
uh i did one of their first series of
stories on illegal immigration in the
united states outside the
mexican border you know the kind of
immigration that comes out of the
the south of south america and central
america and the islands up into the
northeast and the cities and the years i
mean i've done
i i did principal coverage on the
child killings in atlanta
when they're recurring but i suppose the
i mean i've done
wander from one one subject to another i
was marginally involved in the hud
investigation last year but the
the story which i'm principally known i
suppose
involved a surgeon in new jersey uh
who
was ultimately charged with murdering
patients in a hospital
and
we called him for a time dr x
and
during his trial the new york times
myself were subpoenaed for our entire
file including confidential materials
and
and uh in the end while he was acquitted
although he subsequently lost his
license on other cases in the united
states and and moved back to argentina
and died although he was acquitted of
the murder charges i went to jail
for refusing to disclose confidential
sources how long were you in jail
i faced about a year and a half in jail
but i got i was released after uh 40
days
40 days what jail
the bergen county jail
bergen county is a county in new jersey
northern new jersey was it worth it
um
yes it was worth it
it was worth it uh not only because it
allowed me to hold my head up by
having uh having adhered to the promises
that i had made as a journalist
um it was worth it to take a stand
because uh
because the statutes in new jersey and a
number of other states
were changed subsequently
and in the very
in the new jersey supreme court where we
lost five to two
as a result of my efforts i believe
the next case came along the reporter
won six to one
after a change in the law
so i think it was worth it
those of you who have just joined us our
guest is m.a farber he is with the new
york times a reporter and investigative
reporter as he just told us and this is
what the book looks like it's called
outrage the story behind the tawanna
brawley hoax
could we just take a moment and go
through the rest of the folks that
co-authored this book with you and tell
us something about them
ralph blumenthal
ralph blumenthal does essentially the
same kind of work that i do
um
generally complex uh uh
conf you know confused situations and uh
um
the uh the first author robert mcfadden
is the
probably the premier
what's known in the business as rewrite
man
in the united states
certainly the dean of rewrite of the new
york times for the last quarter century
and i like to say that when the
when the world
explodes should it ever explode it'd be
mcfadden writing the story for the times
and um
uh
charles strom is an editor at the times
who
was the principal editor
on the stories that the times wrote
and craig wolf is a younger reporter
covers now federal court manhattan
e.r ship is a um
has a legal background and she's covered
law for the times
and is now an assistant metropolitan
editor
and uh i hope i'm not leaving anyone out
there you got them all okay how did you
divide up responsibilities for writing
this book
not easily
the um
you know we have
we all wrote drafts
um rewrote drafts
everyone's material was shown to
everyone else
everyone had opportunity to chat what
seems like countless meetings to you
know suggest revisions
and
finally
mcfadden um
brought it together to give its you know
the fluidity that that a book needs
and um
and uh he's very deft at that at least i
think i believe he's very deft at
um at what time period and
recently did was this actually written
oh it was written throughout
throughout 1989 the early part of 90.
in the uh
in the acknowledgements uh does it feel
strange for you uh to see these words we
wish to express our gratitude in
particular to governor mario cuomo of
new york
uh attorney general robert
abrams
i can go down through the list and then
you you eventually get to the reverend
al sharpton in other words you're
thanking people and who were your
sources
well you know
with
i believe people ought to be thanked for
um
for the time they spend with you for
what is essentially your project
uh going out of their way
that is not
meant to say that as the book will
reflect that i endorse
everything mario cuomo did in this case
or everything al sharpton did in this
case that's not the case and
but um but they they gave us of their
time and thought
in the preparation of this book and i
think they for that they deserve to be
thanked how many hours did
did you spend with governor cuomo
talking about this thing
and did you do it or to somebody else i
was involved in part of that
[Music]
a dozen hours perhaps
i i wish not to be held to that exact
figure because i hadn't thought
i mean i haven't tried to parse that out
but
it's some considerable amount of time
what role did he play in this
well not the book but the whole
situation
uh no i understand um
i think i think like many people at the
beginning when when the story was put
out that she had been raped by a group
of white law enforcement officers that
governor cuomo was very concerned about
that and rightfully so
and um and
he threw his weight behind an
investigation of it and through the
state police weight behind it and
and
and his own criminal justice coordinator
and then he appointed the attorney
general of state the special prosecutor
and
and uh he'd like to point out that he
had children and daughter of his own and
that
he
sympathized with this but he was one of
the he was one of these people at the
beginning who
said surely something had happened to
her
bill cosby you know put up a reward of
25 000 for information leading to the
arrest of those people who
had
who had attacked her
but
but it was only gradually that people
came to understand i think well some
people came to understand the grant that
this wasn't so i mean did something
happen to her
for a 15 year old
to put herself in that position
that's something happening
to her even if it's largely
self-inflicted i mean even if she's put
the excrement on herself
even if she has written the kkk herself
what have you the circumstances that
lead
a veritable child a certain adolescent
to do that then something has happened
to you you know but not the something
that the advisor said
not rape at the hands of white racists
in that county in one of the last
chapters you do tell the story of what
you think actually happened yes how did
you do that
well we drew on
all our knowledge of what we believe to
be the situation and uh are you the only
people that feel it happen this way
no i don't think we're the only people
um i mean is this a count is this
account in this book fresh as far as
you're concerned are there elements of
it that have never been published before
well there's certain particulars in that
book that have never been published
before i mean i'll give you an example
of that where that
there comes a time
when
when
alt maddox one of her lawyers who as i
said earlier had now been barred from
pricing in new york pending his
cooperation with investigation
uh handling of the case
where he publicly names a prosecutor in
dutchess county as one of the rapists
now
um
automatics would tell you that that he
believes that texas county new york
that's right that he believes that
but
there isn't a shred of evidence to
support that
in my view
but when he names pogonis at a press
conference
when he names this assistant prosecutor
who is now suing for 800 million or
something
um al sharpton
turns his head
never
he doesn't know what maddox is talking
about
now this is the extent
of their
real knowledge you see it's it's a sort
of
you know um
as as we go along
we'll we'll sort of tell this thing to
the public you see but but uh
charlotte is mystified himself i mean
charlton was representing her as a real
victim before he uh before long before
he had met her
um
i i believe that that the people who
have essentially maintained the case
that she was raped have never really
gotten a clear story from her
but you will see that kind you know you
what the book gives you
uh
and that's great what the book gives you
is
not only those things that are fresh but
it gives you a picture of how it is all
going where where where things are
happening both in the brawley family and
the brawley camp and the governor's mind
and the attorney general's office uh uh
it gives you
that picture and an end in
uh mrs smith's little coffee shop it
gives you that picture as it's happening
uh it was of course one couldn't do that
when writers need writing news stories
because you only knew as much as you
knew at a given date at that time i mean
it really really required some stepping
back afterward to be able to produce
this book
in the middle of your book there's a
fairly dramatic account of uh
your
personal investigative work in in
[Music]
in finding the the summaries of the
you're shaking your head
[Laughter]
i've done hard work but anyway
don't understand i'm not suggesting that
you haven't done hard work but i mean
there this is a dramatic part of this
book where you talk about
i don't know what was it two two o'clock
in the morning you call some source of
yours and i mean tell the story about
the why are the summaries what were they
and why are they important to your your
story here the
i don't think anyone outside of us have
ever seen the summaries
um um
it developed
that during the state's investigation
that mario cuomo had set in motion
that um summaries of the state's
evidence and and interviews
what they knew
from a vast amount of work
uh were being done
they were being summoned all this
vomiting was being summarized so to
speak
some of which went to the grand jury
that was here that was trying to decide
whether crime had been committed
and um
and
fairly late in the times coverage
uh uh ralph blumenthal and i discovered
uh in conversation with a source
uh who had contacts with the government
that there were such summaries we didn't
know that ourselves
and you know in a parochial kind of way
we were concerned
that my god some other news media is
liable to get these summaries and and uh
and uh before we ever got them i mean
there's still that pride in work of uh
newspapering and um
but we also want to know what they said
and ralph and i walked out of a meeting
having just heard about the existence of
these summaries and
somewhat dumbfounded and wondering what
we could do about it
when on the way home i had an idea
and placed a telephone call
as you say it was two three in the
morning or something 2 40 am i believe
and
by
sunup i had the summaries
and then you had the front page article
in new york time
as a result of the summaries which said
what
which said that
that um in four fashion that when we
that we have been able to say before
that uh
that um there wasn't no
uh evidence to support
a rape
of tawanabrali that there was much
evidence to the contrary this is the
first time this had ever been published
there certainly had been suggestions of
that before
but this what what appeared was
a essentially a
preview of what indeed the grand jury
ultimately found as well
that there wasn't any evidence of that
kind
but
i don't want to make more of it than it
was it was a journalistic
scoop if you will
it certainly
it certainly uh helped to solidify our
own thinking
gather from our own work that we had
been doing
[Music]
as to what the evidence in this case
pointed to how long after this story was
published it's also much more particular
than in many areas than we were ever
able to know without that
how much uh longer after your story was
published to the grand jury actually
published
or i think they released their report in
october i think that story was in
september
what about the issue of
grand jury's supposed to be private
is private
supposed to be private you made them
non-private
well
al
alton maddox and al sharpton like to run
around saying why don't we prosecute
those felonious new york times reporters
uh
um
um
who stole the grand jury minutes that's
the way i think they generally freeze
uh we never had any grand jury minutes
as i understand grand jury minutes they
are
q and a
and i've seen some that have been
legally obtained
um
and it's like a court transcript
but we didn't have the grand jury
minutes we've never had the grand jury
minutes what we had were summaries of
evidence
that were in the hands of of many people
many people within the government or
some people within the government
who wouldn't have been entitled to grand
jury minutes either
did you identify all of the members of
the grand jury
in any of your stories no we didn't but
i think that you do have some in this
book
yes we do have some in the book
uh some of the grand jurors spoke to us
afterward about their experience about
the kinds of evidence that meant
something to them
gave us a feel for what it was like to
be a grand juror
in a this predominately white county
about a racially explosive case
and
they were considerable help and i think
that that is
by and large all fresh as you say
fresh in the book and
but i think that
that
expanding beyond those particular grand
juries i think it meant a lot to the
grand jury as i understand this that
that
that
that
that
forensic psychiatrist who testified
before the grand jury
did not think that this case fit
anything like the pattern of what would
have been a rape of this sort
um first of all there was no physical
evidence physical signs of rape
uh her account of having been in the
woods and beyond professional science
there were other forensic experts i mean
there was no
she
there was no
plant
material for example
on her body whatever i mean
if she had been in the woods for any
length of time fbi experts testified
it's inconceivable that she wouldn't
have had picked up as the body picks up
this kind of material
to the contrary
she had under her fingernail clippings
which had been taken when she was taken
to the hospital
certain fibers that were associated with
fibers from a washcloth piece of burnt
washcloth underneath found under the bag
that she that she put herself into and
that were also found on the floor of her
old apartment
that tended to support
the idea that she had
had
had wet these fibers had wet this
washcloth and had written these things
on herself i mean you know rapists
generally don't
put
go out of the way to put fibers what
they're doing on to under the
fingernails of
the victim i mean it's
there's a so the book offers perhaps the
clearest explanation
of what the
what the refined evidence in the case
points to
and
it does not support the notion of a rape
to the contrary
how much
is the media in new york city to blame
for either making al sharpton what he is
today
if you think he's
not what he pertains himself to be and
how much are they to blame for making
this story
what it is
well look back on it i mean the
the um
it's after howard beach
people were saying she her family is
saying that she was raped by a group of
white men
law enforcement officers
[Music]
these things can happen
the media ceased upon it but but
but they
it wasn't really it wasn't really until
it really wasn't until the advisor
started to whip it up so to speak that
it got to be the story that it became a
national story with international
attention that sort of thing i don't i
don't think the media is to blame here i
think that the
the media it's um
you know in the aftermath of mayor
barry's trial people
have some people have blamed the media
for promoting
an anti-black sentiment and
and i
i don't
subscribe to it and i don't subscribe to
it in this case i
um
anyone who knows the tabloids of new
york
knows that
um it's a story that that inherently had
sensational elements of this case was
going to be
widely reported
and and
and
[Music]
i'm not here to you know i really just
don't want i'm not here to try to censor
the tabloids i i don't
um
do i think all newspapers ought to do a
more thorough job than they do on any
important story yes i do um
do i think uh that you you that
newspapers are always going to do the
most thorough story that could be done
no they're not through time constraints
and other constraints
but i don't think i know as far as al
sharpton goes i
he has gotten a lot of publicity
he knows how to manipulate that policy
he knows how to create that publicity
um
and um
and i think for the foreseeable future
he has
ready access to it
[Music]
for good or bad
i don't think the media has created him
though i think the media may have
may have fostered him may have promoted
him along the way
but
there are a lot of politicians in new
york
who
and other public figures who wish they
had the
you know they may rant and rave at
sharpton too
but
if they could gather together the press
as quickly as al sharpton can
they'd probably be pretty happy about it
back to your uh story about the
summaries um
you
share with us in the book some of the
problems you had with getting that story
in the paper
and suggesting that you you kept going
back to your editors and they said no no
not yet
um
is that is that a normal part of the
process that it's is it tough for you to
get some of your stories in
uh you know i've worked practically my
entire career at the times i'm familiar
with that their practices
i'm not that familiar with practices of
other newspapers there we have layer
upon layer
of editing
and
what may satisfy an editor at one level
only raises a question uh
in an editor at another level
and you literally have to clear
all these hurdles
on a major story before
it gets into the newspaper
i mean you could liken to to to you know
it's a system of checks uh
and
of course it doesn't always work either
but
um i don't have any concern about
meeting uh
i don't have any concern about meeting
those checks i mean i do it all the time
i
um
i like to think that over a period of
time i've developed myself even a sixth
sense about
what what the reader's law would ask
that i can't answer and i go try to find
the answer even before even before any
reader ever had an opportunity to erase
it you say
this is what i suppose experience
gives you
um by the way what was tawanna brawley
up to
what was she up to i think she was a
scared young woman a scared girl
who
wanted to be
[Music]
back in the good graces of
her stepfather
and
and the mother was sympathized to that
and she had run away before
she had stayed out late before as many
adolescents do
part of the most serious crime in the
world and
and in misguided
misguided ways she concocted this
terrible appearance of herself
often with the help of her mother
sympathetic sympathetic you understand i
mean to keep it within the family you
would say
you know and um
and um
you know how could any stepfather or how
could any man be angry at his child who
was found in such a condition you see
who had been attacked you know even if
she had ran a run away for a few days
how could he possibly be angry
but it was carried to extreme and that
extreme was very very much carried to
extreme once
other members of the family not even
knowing that it wasn't so
decided to bring in the f to call the
fbi and to call the media where the
governor was all of a sudden on the spot
and sympathetic to it and and the ball
starts rolling and these advisers who
are brought in
who are no shrinking violets of nothing
else
and
and it just goes on and on and on and
i think that what the book hopefully
what the book succeeds in doing in part
is
is giving
the reader some sense of
what happens on the inside when these
kinds of developments occur
why do people draw certain conclusions
why do people whether he's the governor
or or al sharpton or anyone or or just
the management why do they react the way
they do why do they then take the
position that they do
um i mean i think that for example mario
cuomo
mario cuomo um
essentially i think views himself as a
man of reason who can
reason with anybody
and
and
what's necessary is to bring al sharpton
and automatics and vernon mason together
in a room with him and sit down and
explain the situation and let's reason
together and
and we'll all come out of the room
thinking alike
but
but that but al sharpton and vernon
mason and automatics they're on a
different wavelength i mean they
you know their
their perspective is
this country
has had a racist history that needs to
be corrected
and
and
we have to put the white establishment
in order in a way it's not going to
allow itself to be put in order
and
so their
viewpoint as well as their agenda as
well as how they react to things and
what they do
is different than what perhaps mario
cuomo might expect and you see this
happening in the book
and you see how
you know people are
very often talking at
each other but not talking to each other
a bonfire of the vanities
uh
uh there's an element of that there
yeah
i mean
talk about just publishing books is that
bonfire the vanity is one of the big
hits of the last several years a fiction
book by tom wolf
the reverend bacon is he the reverend
sharpton
that's what some say now
how does this happen i mean you know
you've undoubtedly thought about this
how do you how do you have this book of
fiction that turns out now you've got a
book
three quarters of the size and it's it's
almost
it's the real thing yeah but bonfire the
vanities is a much
different framework yeah and different
cast of characters and it's a novel as
you say and
and uh
it's uh
uh
it's got a
the the rich whites of the bonfire the
values i mean this is a uh i i think the
reason it was likened
to the al
associated with it
some people's minds was because of this
character reverend bacon who's a sort of
outsized character
and and um
and uh al sharpton
is that and and he's been he's been so
vivid on the new york scene in
particular
that tom wolf could probably couldn't
have failed to notice him you see
although i'm sure there's at the
beginning of tom's books tomorrow's book
it says all these characters are
fictional and unrelated to real people
and all that sort of thing you know but
uh i've never talked to tom wolf about
this and so i don't know firsthand
whether he had sharpened in mine or not
but i do want to say that that
a lot of a lot of people
laughed at the character of reverend
bacon and bonfire the vanity
um
al sharpton has to be
someone to be taken seriously i think
so so is autumn maddox and vernon mason
and others who support them
um
the
but it doesn't but taking them seriously
doesn't mean
[Music]
and listening to them doesn't mean that
they're always right
they may have been writing out howard
beach they may have been right about
bensonhurst even though their tactics
some of their tactics there may have
been deplorable
but they weren't right here in my
opinion in our opinion
try to get them to say that i you know
they
they will tell you they sincerely
believe this is what happened and that
is there's still a coverup they will say
it is still a cover-up and this is part
of the cover-up and you know let's throw
farmer back in jail
you say in the book that al sharpton
spent 20 hours with you
talking about
is this episode for the book or for your
for the book just for the book yeah
yeah what did you learn during those 20
hours a lot
a lot a lot about
a lot that makes the difference between
newspaper stories and the book
a lot that that puts
flesh on bones
now
with al sharpton as with
as with others
uh one tries then to verify and check
and recheck you know what what he says
and
and um
and uh so some material was not used at
all and some material was used i mean
this ultimately gets to be a question of
you know your level of confidence in a
particular
anecdote that might be related or that
sort of thing who wouldn't talk to you
tawanna brawley
her mother and her stepfather
uh tomorrowley her mother
although al sharpton introduced me once
to her mother
and to
her stepfather to tuana's mother and
stepfather
um we've spoken briefly with them but
but that was but for the book
to want to
broaden the tawanna brawler's immediate
family did not cooperate
we did have discussions however with her
aunt
juanita
uh who um
you know i believe uh you know never
knew that it was a certainly not in the
beginning that it was a hoax and uh
and um and was genuinely concerned about
the whereabouts of this girl who had
you know
for all appearances disappear for four
days and um
and uh
and believe that something terrible had
happened to her
we spoke to a native problem the state
and your opinion of race relations today
start with new york city and then
go beyond that
i don't
um
i don't want to pretend to be an expert
you know a grand expert
race relations i mean do i think i know
what i'm talking about when i write
something i think so
am i better positioned than you are to
judge race relations
um
i don't think so
um i think that um that um
however that um
new york city is a uh
is it
a potential tinder box
in terms of race relations
um and um
that's where i think that al sharpton
has been more inflammatory than he than
he ought to be
um and um
the
and i'm sure that that is uh
that's true uh
i mean i believe that to be true
in my
from my own reading of many urban areas
in the united states that that
that state of race relations uh isn't
good and um i think it
has much to do with um
a a
gap in poverty between the rich and the
poor
a growing gap that as much as the actual
color of anyone's skin
the
how could you know
i mean
new york city alone has a tremendous
population of young people who black men
who have no work
i mean this is
i mean there are there are profound
situations in new york schools that had
a long way to go before providing
anything like an acceptable education in
many areas
in those kinds of situations you can't
help but have
a a an antsy situation you know
the potential for a real problem
and um
and fortunately
what happened in bensonhurst did not
lead to uh
any greater kind of dilemma than it did
and the
uh but the potential is there
and that's where many people would fault
an al sharpton because they they feel
that he exploits those situations and
one of these days it's going to come
down on the head of everybody
um
but
it's it's
it's important to
if you're going to make any headway i
think in in racial harmony
for uh people to uh separate out uh the
truth from fiction and and
wanna brawly
story or the story as put out by the
advisors
um
in our opinion is not uh
is not the truth and these and that
needs to be said that's what we're
doing here and we're doing it we hope in
a way that
that readers can follow and understand
it much much more so than they would
have from newspaper stories
do you like what you do and if you do
why
as a reporter do i like what i do
um
well i'd have to be a damn fool to be
doing it for as long as i've been doing
it without liking it i suppose but
um
you know i essentially see it as a
public service job
you know i'm mindful
of all those people out there who
you know
you know
think the press you know is a
self-appointed group of righteous people
and you know that uh who are they to
pronounce judgments and all that sort of
thing i i know they're out there and i
but um
i don't know any uh
i don't know anything better than the
way it's set up now and as a reporter
for new york times i've had you know an
opportunity to
to
[Music]
to
i think
shed
bring some light to many subjects
i think we have achieved that here
and i like that it's
it's a good way to live and it is
it's
in the public interest is there anything
you haven't done yet in this business
that you're pitching to do
get more space
than some editor says i can have
i
uh the
the um
i'd have to think long and hard about
that
it's pretty interesting as it is
the book is outrage
story behind the tawana bralee hoax
as written by our guest m.a farber and
his cohorts at the new york times thank
you for your time my pleasure
join us next week on booknotes when we
discuss american racial issues with
jeanette dates co-author of split image
african americans in the mass media
an associate dean at howard university
school of communications ms dates
explains the historical development of
black white relations in this country
and discusses her own views of the
racial situation as it exists today
that's jeanette dates next week on book
notes
coming up next an interview with sir
michael alexander britain's permanent
representative to the north atlantic
council
[Music]
go behind the scenes